Because of climate change, mountain glaciers are melting rapidly,
and affecting numerous ecosystems,
but getting up-close readings
on these high-altitude environments is difficult.
Satellite images don’t have enough detail,
and can be easily thwarted by clouds.
Airplanes can map glaciers in high resolution,
but the cost can be astronomical.
Oliver Wigmore, a scientist at the University of Colorado,
has developed a new high-flying drone,
that can take images at altitudes of up
to 6000 meters above sea level.
Normally, drones have trouble reaching these
heights, because the air is too thin
for their propellers to build up enough lift.
But with this new design, weight is kept to a minimum.
The tiny aircraft only weighs 2 kilograms,
and with 6 individual rotors each over a foot long,
generating lift shouldn’t be a problem.
To give their UAV a shakedown cruise,
researchers took it to the heights of the Andes mountains in South America,
where 70% of the Earth’s tropical ice is located,
and melting glaciers are often what supplies freshwater
to communities in the summer.
With the drone’s help, researchers are able
to get closeup pictures
and create detailed models of the glacier surface.
Using drone surveys collected one year apart,
scientists are able see where,
and how quickly the glacier ice is melting.
While the flights through the Andes were the
first test of the UAV,
it was only the first stop on a world tour.
The researchers are taking it to even greater
heights in the Andes, and are using this kind of
closeup data gathering for other environmental studies,
in places like the mountains of Colorado.